quel est le meilleur smartphone entre
deux côtés l'iPhone 14 pro max le
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra et le pixel 7
Pro 3 smartphones très haut de gamme
super intéressant qu'on va venir
comparer alors ils sont complètement
différents sur plein de points parce
qu'ils ont chacun leur propre puce chez
Apple vous avez la puce maison chez
Google hop là il est là vous avez
également une puce maison la nouvelle
tensor et pour la première fois depuis
très longtemps on retrouve un processeur
de Qualcomm c'est le saint dragon 8 GN2
dans ce nouveau smartphone le Samsung
Galaxy S23
ultra donc trois puces différentes trois
blocs photos différents pour réussir à
savoir quel est le meilleur smartphone
en photo quel est le meilleur photophone
dans le très haut de gamme on va tout
regarder des photos de nuit des photos
de jour on va regarder de la nourriture
du mode portrait des selfies ça a très
complet ça risque de durer un peu
longtemps parce que franchement c'est un
sujet qui est très passionnant on va
mettre les photos côte à côte on va les
regarder on va les comparer on va
essayer de comprendre réellement ce qui
se passe quels sont les choix quels sont
les points faibles est-ce que forcément
il y en a qu'elles sont les points forts
dans le très haut de gamme je vous le
dis tout de suite ça va envoyer du bois
il va falloir aller un peu chipoter
faudra être très exigeant vous êtes prêt
allez on y va
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec Odou si
vous souhaitez notamment venir créer
votre site internet totalement
gratuitement et bien vous pouvez le
faire avec au double et si vous êtes
également une PME que vous cherchez une
solution tout en un pour faire plein de
choses et bien au doux également là pour
vous regarder je vous montre Audoux vous
permettra entre autres et bien si vous
êtes une entreprise de gérer vos
finances ressources humaines la vente
marketing le site web plein de services
des inventeurs de la productivité mais
si vous voulez faire votre site web très
facilement et pourquoi pas un site de
e-commerce je vous mets le lien en bas
dans la description et bien c'est super
simple regardez je vous montre moi je
suis en train de faire mon site internet
et bien regardez c'est très simple vous
avez pas besoin d'avoir des
connaissances en code je vous montre ici
j'ai plein de blogs que je peux venir
mettre une bannière une cover du texte
un titre et compagnie moi par exemple je
veux commencer avec une petite cover hop
là je la prends je la glisse je peux
venir éditer très facilement modifier
mes textes coucou ici Monsieur greu
alors je sais c'est pas terrible ce que
j'écris mais vous allez trouver beaucoup
mieux je m'en doute il y a aucun
problème vous venez modifier la couleur
derrière plan vous avez beaucoup de
possibilités c'est très très simple et
super intuitif la police la forme bref
on peut faire ça très très facilement si
vous voulez mettre un titre en dessous
vous prenez vous peser vous glissez vous
pouvez venir le modifier par exemple un
petit qui suis-je hop là et vous voulez
mettre en dessous un petit texte pour
expliquer ce que vous faites et bien
regardez je suis monsieur greu je fais
des vidéos etc etc etc j'en passe et des
meilleurs et c'est pas simple vous
prenez vous glissez vous déposez un
texte une image en dessous paf je mets
ça et si je veux que mon texte soit un
peu plus haut et bien regardez je prends
ça je viens sélectionner je viens de
monter c'est un système de grille en
fait donc c'est super simple vous prenez
vous le déplacez vous le mettez où vous
voulez c'est super intuitif pas besoin
de savoir coder vous pouvez mettre votre
logo en haut aussi très facilement par
exemple je viens choisir mon logo
monsieur gros que je l'ai retrouvé là
bref je peux faire tout ce que je veux
très facilement créer plein de pages et
tout ça gratuitement oui parce que
la pro et si vous en voulez plus à
partir de deux applications distinctes
et bien vous allez commencer à rentrer
sur un plan payant foncez découvrir au
doux je vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description vous débutez gratuitement
avec une application et si vous avez
besoin
de Picasso vous allez pouvoir les
utiliser à des tarifs maîtriser et en
plus de ça le service est de qualité et
ça c'est chouette merci à oudou d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo une fois de plus
le lien est en bas dans la description
la première chose en tout cas ça doit
resituer très très rapidement ce qu'on
retrouve au niveau matériel alors ici
sur l'iPhone vous avez trois capteurs à
l'arrière on a un grand angle de 48
mégapixels qui nous permet de faire un
zoom numérique x 2 vous avez un
téléobjectif de 12 mégapixels avec un
zoom optique x 3 donc le X 2 et
numérique par du 48 mégapixels tandis
que l'optique c'est du x 3 qui part du
12 mégapixels et ici on va jusqu'à zoom
numérique x 15 et on a un ultra
grand-angle de 12 mégapixels tandis qu'à
l'avant et bien vous avez une caméra de
selfie qui est planqué ici dans dynamic
Island de 12 mégapixels ça c'est pour
l'iPhone 14 pro max pour le Samsung
Galaxy S23 ultra qui est beaucoup plus
récent vous allez avoir un grand angle
de 200 mégapixels qui est très très cool
vous allez avoir un ultra grand-angle de
12 mégapixels un premier téléobjectif de
10 mégapixels avec un zoom optique x 3
et un deuxième téléobjectif toujours 10
mégapixels avec un zoom optique x 10 qui
vous permet d'aller jusqu'au space zoom
x 100 et vous avez également une caméra
de selfie à l'avant qui est planqué
quelque part ici là dans la petite bande
noire et bien c'est une caméra de selfie
de 12 mégapixels tandis que sur le pixel
7 pro et bien vous vous avez à l'arrière
un grand angle de 50 mégapixels vous
allez avoir un ultra grand angle de 12
mégapixels et un téléobjectif zoom
optique x5 qui va jusqu'à 1 x 30 et une
caméra de selfie qui est planqué tout en
haut ici qui a une caméra de 10,8
mégapixels donc mise à part le Samsung
Galaxy S23 ultra qui a 2 téléobjectif
faisons chacun un grand angle un ultra
grand-angle et un tel objectif allez on
y va on regarde les photos à gauche ici
on va voir le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra
au centre le Google pixel 7 pro et à
droite l'iPhone donc là ce qu'on voit
directement c'est qu'on est une
différence de colorimétrie on voit que
l'iPhone va faire ressortir davantage
les Bleus ça va être un peu plus saturé
on a aussi une petite différence aussi
au niveau des teintes globales mais ça
je vais vous le montrer un petit peu
après pour qu'on essaye de bien tout
voir dans dans son ensemble donc là j'ai
franchement tout de suite sur cette
première photo je vois pas grand chose
de de très choquant de très notable ça
marche bien c'est beau d'un côté comme
de l'autre on va plus on avance plus on
est saturé voyons par Samsung bon c'est
bleu ça fonctionne c'est correct ici
c'est un peu plus ça pas plus saturé
c'est un peu différent l'expo les scouts
un peu un petit peu en dessous et ici au
niveau de l'iPhone c'est un peu plus
saturé ça peut être c'est plus chaud on
y va directement donc là on avance assez
grand angle ça c'est l'ultra grand-angle
vous voyez la différence là mon ultra
grand-angle il devient un peu plus
saturé du côté de chez Samsung par
rapport à celui de l'iPhone ce qui est
intéressant tout de suite avoir c'est au
niveau du soleil voyez je veux bien mais
rayon du soleil qui sont bien détachés
chez Samsung qui le sont un petit peu
moins sur le pixel et là sur l'iPhone on
parle plus ici de de rayons de soleil là
on parle du soleil et d'une tâche c'est
un peu différent on essaie de voir un
peu les détails c'est vraiment là on va
voir les les différentes choses on a
bien de la matière ici on devine bien ce
qu'on retrouve ici au niveau de de ce
monument qui est à Trafalgar Square si
je dis pas de bêtises à Londres je vous
emmène à Londres on est à Londres là là
on devine également là on le voit un peu
moins c'est plus compliqué un peu plus
contrasté un peu plus d'ombre un peu
plus forte ici sur l'iPhone on continue
alors on va passer ici sur le
téléobjectif on passe sur le Samsung on
est sur zoom optique x 3 donc sur le X 3
c'est bien alors j'ai dû bouger là sur
le pixel parce que vous voyez c'est un
peu impression c'est moi qui bougeait
ici sur l'iPhone ça fonctionne également
mais là je suis en X 2 et là je suis en
X 3 donc dans les deux cas si vous voyez
là et là je suis en X 3 optique tandis
que sur là je sais pas pourquoi je suis
pas voilà ma famille en optique dès
qu'on se rapproche et je vous le dis
tout de suite prendre bien vous allez le
voir Samsung ça reste quand même le
champion de toute catégorie au niveau du
zoom grâce à ces combos x 3 x 10 et
jusqu'au x 30 c'est pas mal au-delà bon
vous voyez sur le Space zoom on peut se
rapprocher mais on va commencer un peu à
perdre qualité mais par contre on va pas
aller bien plus loin du côté du pixel où
on va tout de suite avoir beaucoup plus
de mal et voyez dès qu'on se rapproche
c'est pas ça l'iPhone on peut se
rapprocher aussi c'est pas mauvais mais
arrive un moment où ça fonctionne plus
il y a le pixel là il a dit au revoir
depuis longtemps tandis que du côté de
chez Samsung on peut continuer à venir
bricoler à se rapprocher bon on va pas
non plus aller trop trop loin mais quand
même on peut autre photo qui est
intéressante également ici parce que
vous avez effectivement les bâtiments il
y a des zones d'ombre des hommes qui ne
sont pas d'ombre entre l'iPhone ici le
Google ici et puis le Samsung alors là
ce qu'on va tout de suite qu'est-ce qui
est très très intéressant ici c'est la
différence de colorimétrie de base c'est
à dire que si vous regardez sur votre
smartphone de Samsung on a un peu plus
de vert vous allez le voir ici au niveau
du sol l'eau va être un peu plus
turquoise parce que si vous comparez
avec le Google qui lui aura un petit peu
moins de verre il y aura un plus de
violer légèrement plus de violet c'est
pas ici qu'on le verra le plus et sur
l'iPhone on est un peu entre les deux
c'est un peu plus vert également c'est
pas aussi vert que sur le smartphone de
Samsung mais c'est un peu plus vert et
c'est un peu moins violet que sur Google
le pixel voilà c'est c'est vraiment ce
qu'il faut venir retenir ici ça change
un peu du coup la colorimétrie au niveau
du bleu du ciel fatalement le fait
d'avoir un peu plus de bleu un peu plus
de violet mais dans l'ensemble les trois
sont très bonnes juste cette différence
de colorimétrie qu'on vient retrouver
ici après c'est vraiment du point de
détail lorsque je me mets à contre-jour
bon s'en sort plutôt pas trop trop mal
j'ai l'impression que on a un peu plus
les rayons du soleil sur le Galaxy S23
ultra un peu moins sur le Google pixel
pro sur l'iPhone c'est pas non plus ouf
mais dans l'ensemble le taf est fait et
ils s'en sort pas trop trop mal on va
continuer ici avec toujours cette
colonne à Trafalgar Square ce qu'on va
vraiment ici c'est la différence de
colorimétrie il y a pas gros grosses
différences de détails on le verra plus
sur ce qu'on aura des photos de nuit
mais voyez ici là on devine davantage le
côté un peu plus violet ici le côté un
peu plus vert et aussi légèrement plus
vert ici vous voyez c'est un choix
colorimétrique on fait les les
fabricants de de smartphone ici pour le
voy également sur la colonne un peu plus
violet sur le pix sur le Galaxy sur le
S23 un peu moins et sur l'iPhone 14 pro
max et bien c'est pareil voilà c'est ces
petits points de détails après c'est à
vous de voir dites-moi vous qu'est-ce
que vous préférez est-ce que vous
préférez la colorimétrie de base du
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra est-ce qu'on
peut faire celle du Google pixel 7 pro
ou est-ce que vous préférez ça doit
aller faire 14 programmes c'est marqué
le mot en bas vous marquez colorimétrie
vous marquez le modèle comme ça on verra
un peu vers lequel votre cœur penche
après la grosse différence et c'est une
fois de plus les zooms les téléobjectif
hein regardez déjà on est là on est sur
le faut 10 optique le boulot est
vraiment beaucoup plus joli dès qu'on
vient se rapprocher sur un équivalent X
au niveau du pixel bon on se retrouve
tout de suite beaucoup moins bien et sur
l'iPhone alors on peut venir se
rapprocher un peu plus mais voyez là où
l'iPhone il est encore un peu de mal ça
reste très net très détaillé
l'algorithme bosse aussi super bien du
Sun dragon 8 gène 2 et très très bon sur
le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra donc en
termes de téléobjectif si vous voulez
venir zoomer dans l'image je vous le dis
directement le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra
les entères tous les deux choses soient
claires ça veut pas dire que c'est pas
bon ça veut dire que c'est très bon mais
qu'on va aller beaucoup moins loin si
vous voulez venir zoomer dans votre
photo voilà ça il faut quand même bien
le sachant que plus vous allez aller
loin avec le Space zoom au-delà du X 30
la qualité va se dégrader même si l'algo
vient compenser certaines choses autre
point qui est intéressant très
intéressant ici c'est ce qu'on va voir
sur le casque au niveau du garde sur le
smartphone de Samsung on a bien la
couleur dorée ça reste maîtrisé là on
est plus exposé au soleil là on est plus
dans une zone d'ombre mais tout est très
correct d'un côté comme de l'autre là si
j'arrive sur le pixel c'est un peu
différent le côté qui est plus exposé va
être un peu plus de mal vous voyez là il
est mieux récupéré sur le Samsung là il
a un peu plus de mal et l'autre zone
elle est un peu plus sombragée alors
c'est peut-être un peu plus naturel
c'est ce qu'on va davantage de l'avoir
avec ses yeux mais ça dépend une fois de
plus qu'on aime c'est vraiment une
question de goût de couleur ici sur
l'iPhone le job est plutôt bien fait
mais voyez là c'est un peu plus cramé
ici ici c'est aussi légèrement plus
cramé tandis que si je viens un peu plus
zoomer voyez sur le Samsung Galaxy S23
ultra et bien je récupère tout de suite
un peu plus de détails donc ça c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant parce que ça
montre vraiment que Samsung va mieux
gérer les hautes lumières va mieux gérer
cette balance au niveau de l'exposition
par rapport à ces deux concurrents à ces
deux compétiteurs dans ce challenge qui
est complètement complètement fou on va
continuer ici avec Big Ben alors c'est
pareil une fois de plus c'est la même
remarque c'est à dire que photo prise
exactement au même endroit à chaque fois
même moment même endroit même
temporalité et bien il s'en sort quand
même vachement mieux le Galaxy S23 ultra
bien qu'il soit un peu plus vers là
après je préférais le verrouille une
fois de plus et bien je trouve que ça
ressort davantage il arrive mieux à
sortir les détails à mieux exposer et il
y a un vrai beau boulot qui est ici pour
autant les deux autres sont très bien
ils sont très bons attention mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a un petit truc en plus du
côté de chez Samsung avec cette version
là vous voyez là j'ai plus de détails
c'est plus net c'est plus joli l'expo
est différente c'est un peu plus foncé
c'est un peu moins bien exposé du côté
du pixel 7 et pareil au niveau de
l'iPhone je vais me rapprocher un petit
peu hop là là et c'est pareil les photos
au niveau du Galaxy sont bien meilleurs
franchement c'est vraiment pas la même
chose ici et une fois de plus avec le
Space zoom il vient les enterrer très
clairement vous voyez la différence elle
est folle ça c'est Google pixel 7 Pro ça
c'est le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra et
l'iPhone il a indiqué il n'ira pas aussi
loin très clairement et on peut
continuer d'aller plus loin que le Space
zoom là on continue sur la tamis ça
serait très intéressant c'est vraiment
la colorimétrie ici qu'on vient vraiment
voir Galaxy S23 ultra c'est plus vert on
va être un peu plus violine vous le
voyez vraiment c'est violet et
maintenant on le voit au niveau des
rayons du soleil et l'iPhone est aussi
un petit peu plus verte très légèrement
un peu plus même un peu plus bleu sur
cette photo là bon on a du lait flair
qu'on va retrouver à cause du soleil en
face rien de bien surprenant ici ici
j'ai pas vu grand chose de différent si
ce n'est au niveau de la colorimétrie
mais sinon bon les trois tiennes sont
très très bien le taf est fait d'un côté
et de l'autre c'est très bien c'est joli
beaucoup de détails ici du côté de
l'iPhone j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un
peu moins de piquets je sais pas
pourquoi je vois un peu moins de piquer
sur le pixel 7 pro et le piqué et toi tu
as un peu moins prononcé si mais très
légèrement ça moi une fois de plus de
détails on est vraiment dans le millimi
détails sur le Galaxy S23
ultra quoi que je suis vraiment pas sûr
du tout non les deux sont vraiment très
très bon là-dessus on continuera ça
devient intéressant parce que vous voyez
on va avoir toute cette question de
haute lumière au fond comment est-ce
qu'il vient gérer un tunnel qui est très
sombre avec des lumières artificielles
et avec une lumière du jour au fond et
bien vous voyez c'est là où le Galaxy
S23 très très bon c'est que on va
récupérer beaucoup plus de détails ici
alors que ça va être davantage cramé sur
les deux autres c'est pas complètement
cramé attention du smartphone très haut
de gamme mais c'est du point détail on
vient chercher le point de détails la
gestion de la haute lumière sera bien
meilleure sur le Galaxy S23 ultra par
rapport à ces deux concurrents donc là
c'est pareil là ici on a la lumière du
jour c'est très bien maîtrisé ici sur le
pixel 7 pro et bien c'est beaucoup moins
bien maîtrisé l'expo est beaucoup plus
complexe sur l'iPhone c'est aussi
beaucoup plus complexe et c'est beaucoup
mieux maîtrisé beaucoup mieux je pense
que la puissance de calcul donc
maintenant parce que Google tensor
deuxième génération elle sera en dessous
en termes de performance normalement on
a le chemin dragon 8 GN2 qui est entre
les deux et vous avez la dernière puce
d'Apple qui est vraiment et au dessus
pour autant l'algo est très très bon
travail super bien ici je trouve qu'il
va être meilleur au niveau de Samsung
ici on continue hop là même
questionnement vous voyez là c'est à
l'extérieur on voit pas trop mal ici ah
c'est pas mal ce qui nous a fait le
Google pixel 7 Pro voyez au niveau du
détail si ça sort davantage ici l'iPhone
est aux fraises il y arrive pas je
dirais que là ici c'est vraiment le pix
que cette pro qui va venir s'en sortir
et qui sera quand même meilleur donc ça
c'est très très cool c'est intéressant
de voir ça permet de pondérer un petit
peu le discours on continue ici et pour
moi je préférais ici tout le détail
l'expo la colorimétrie qu'on a sur le
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra alors là c'est
aussi très intéressant parce que vous
voyez là vous avez le ciel extérieur là
vous avez aussi une lumière du jour le
S23 nous fait plus ressortir cette
partie là par rapport aux autres je
trouve beaucoup plus clair beaucoup
mieux exposé on peut venir se rapprocher
et voyez c'est pareil je trouve qu'on a
plus de détails et je préfère ce que
nous propose Samsung ici par rapport à
ce que nous propose de Google pixel 7
pro et l'iPhone 14 pro max après ici je
dirais Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra iPhone
14 pro max et le pixel 7 Pro après autre
photo également ici pareil en termes de
colorimétrie d'exposition de luminosité
je vais d'abord dire le Samsung Galaxy
S23 l'action 14 pro max et ensuite le
pixel 7 Pro alors on continue ici sur
d'autres photos en extérieur toujours de
plein jour là j'aime mieux le détail que
nous sortira ici le pixel 7 Pro on a un
peu moins de piqué c'est un peu plus
flou ici dans la partie centrale de la
City par rapport à ce qu'on va voir sur
pixel 7 euh l'iPhone sera pas mal mon
deuxième position d'abord le pixel 7 pro
et après le le Galaxy S23 ultra on passe
sur l'ultra grand-angle les trois
fonctionnent bien la colorimétrie est
bonne de tous les côtés plus de piquets
ici au niveau de l'iPhone 14 pro max il
faut le dire on le voit vraiment ici
notamment au niveau des briques là on a
beaucoup moins de piqué sur le pixel 7
pro et pas terrible non plus ici au
niveau du Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra
champion au niveau de l'ultra
grand-angle ça va être l'iPhone 14 pro
max on vient se rapprocher davantage de
compensation logiciel au niveau du pixel
7 pro pour nous faire ressortir la City
ici une sortir les traits c'est un peu
plus flou un peu moins de piqué qu'on va
revenir retrouver ici au niveau du
Galaxy S23 ultra et au niveau de la fin
14 pro maxi tient un peu entre les deux
donc vous voyez il y en a certains qui
sont plus fort dans certains points
d'autres un peu moins fort on se
rapproche légèrement c'est là où Samsung
sera une fois de plus le meilleur
lorsque vous venez vous rapprocher c'est
sans appel très clairement ici voilà on
file à Camden alors comme dance
également ici on va regarder moi ce que
je préfère sur ces photos là c'est je
trouve qu'il y a un meilleur piqué au
niveau du Galaxy S23 ultra je trouve
moins bon au niveau du pixel 7 pro et au
niveau de l'iPhone 14 pro max et du Maya
général je trouvais que le pixel 7 Pro
sera un peu en ça par rapport aux deux
autres smartphones donc ça c'est pour la
photo de jour je vais vous montrer
maintenant quelques petits selfies je
vous montre des photos de selfie avec
toujours la même configuration on va
avoir juste ici à gauche le Samsung le
Google le pixel et ici l'iPhone alors
très clairement là je suis venu chercher
un joli contre-jour celui qui s'en sort
le mieux c'est l'iPhone sans appel
clairement c'est beaucoup mieux beaucoup
plus joli et je sais pas ce qui se passe
du côté du pixel au niveau de la gestion
des Noirs au niveau de la colorimétrie
c'est vraiment pas beau je me trouve un
petit peu un teint un peu jeune que
j'aime pas du tout sur le Samsung ici
c'est pas terrible ici pour moi c'est
vraiment l'iPhone alors voyez au niveau
de l'expo il a quand même poussé
davantage mais c'est là où le logiciel
va être bien bien meilleur on continue
ici avec un autre photo et bien là pour
moi ça sera la même chose ça sera
l'iPhone qui sera bien meilleur ici en
photo de selfie par rapport ici au pixel
qui est pas mauvais mais que je trouve
quand même moins bien beaucoup moins le
teint je trouve qu'il y a un teint
davantage sireux il y a un truc qui est
pas très joli au niveau du grain de la
peau ça me plaît beaucoup moins et
tandis que je trouve qu'ici que le
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra c'est pas ouf
euh je préfère vraiment ici le boulot
que fait l'iPhone au niveau de la caméra
de selfie c'est probablement là où ça va
se départager c'est le moment de
regarder la photo de nuit avec ici sur
la gauche toujours le Samsung Galaxy S23
ultra au centre toujours le Google pixel
7 pro et ici l'iPhone 14 pro max alors
vous allez voir pour moi c'est super
intéressant c'est vraiment gros gros
renseignement qu'on va venir retrouver
ici au-delà des fois de voir essayer
d'être un petit peu de bazar qui vient
se promener ici à droite à gauche la
photo que je trouvais la plus belle la
plus nette la plus claire la mieux gérée
c'est la photo du Samsung Galaxy S23
ultra pourquoi parce que vous avez
vraiment toutes ces petites lumières qui
vient du fond au niveau des phares qui
est très jolie et qui ressort super bien
il y a une homogénéité au niveau de la
photo il y a une atmosphère qui ressort
sur le pixel 7 pro c'est bien mais je
trouve ça moins bien regarder au niveau
du ciel là l'ambiance c'est pas la même
il y a une vraie belle ambiance qui se
dégage sur le S23 qu'on a pas forcément
sur pixel 7 pro de la même manière
pareil l'iPhone 14 pro Max est très bien
s'en sort très très bien mais si je la
mets en face de ce que je retrouve ici
avec le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra pour
moi il y a pas photo le S23 ultra et au
dessus ici au niveau de la photo on va
continuer alors ça c'est aussi super
intéressant quartier de Sceaux alors là
aussi clairement il leur met une petite
gifle parce que regardez déjà l'ambiance
globale de la photo au niveau du S23 est
beaucoup plus belle s'il y a une
homogénéité tout ressort tout est bien
géré et surtout regardez au niveau de
saut on voit bien toutes les petites
lampes presque individuellement la
partie centrale en rouge ressort bien
tandis que effectivement là où le pixel
7 Pro sera un peu moins bon on voit bien
les petites lampes elle ressortent mais
on voit moins le rouge au centre c'est
beaucoup moins joli on voit bien les
petites lampes ici également on a moins
le rouge c'est moins joli et je trouve
que le S23 ultra va être beaucoup plus
doux une photo qui est vraiment beaucoup
plus douce vous voyez avec ce ciel cette
lumière au fond se dégrader de bleu en
haut bleu un peu mauve que je trouve
beaucoup plus joli ici par rapport aux
deux autres clairement vraiment une fois
de plus la façade du bâtiment avec le
rouge qui vient lécher qui monte ici qui
est très joli c'est beaucoup moins doux
ici et sur l'iPhone c'est beaucoup plus
dur je trouve la photo est beaucoup
moins belle pareil ici au niveau du
quartier carnabis est beaucoup plus joli
au niveau de l'écriture je vais préférer
aussi toutes les lumières qui sortent
des fenêtres ici par rapport à celle du
pixel et à celle de l'iPhone c'est pas
les mêmes choix qui ont été fait c'est
vraiment une fois de plus une question
d'ambiance générale les deux autres sont
très bons mais quitte à choisir je
préfère de très loin celle du Galaxy S23
ultra on vient regarder ici alors ces
photos il reste super intéressantes au
niveau des lumières j'ai fait exprès de
me positionner là avec des guirlandes
avec une porte ici d'un magasin qui est
ouvert et avec différentes lumières
alors la lumière du vélo on va pas la
prendre en compte mais on va regarder
plus la lumière ici des halogènes que
vous avez juste là qui elles seront un
peu mieux gérer un peu mieux exposer un
peu moins forte par rapport à celle du
pixel c'est le pro qui vont venir
tabasser davantage et celle de l'iPhone
qui est là on se prend en plein phare
dans la gueule soyons clair donc c'est
beaucoup mieux gérer ici pour autant on
voit bien ce qu'il y a dans le magasin à
l'intérieur ici on le voit ici mais sur
le haut c'est un petit peu moins bien au
niveau des hautes lumières et l'iPhone a
beaucoup plus de mal ici au niveau des
hautes lumières le panneau ici au niveau
de la glace est beaucoup plus jolie la
marque de glace est beaucoup plus jolie
ici là c'est un peu plus terne au niveau
de la couleur bon sur l'iPhone ça
fonctionne c'est un peu plus flashy
autre chose les petites loupiotes qu'on
vient retrouver là et puis surtout la
petite vous venez avoir ici vous voyez
et bien ici j'ai bien mes petites
loupiotes ça va ça fonctionne très bien
ici mais ma lumière là elle est beaucoup
plus exposée il a beaucoup plus de mal
vous voyez entre le SAMSUNG et ici le
Google et si vous venez regarder ici
c'est pareil au niveau de l'iPhone et
bien c'est beaucoup plus exposé c'est
beaucoup moins doux donc il y a gestion
de la lumière qui est vraiment bien
meilleur au niveau du Galaxy S23 ultra
on peut lire là pizza pile Green's là je
lis et là sur l'iPhone je ne lis
absolument rien du tout donc voyez il y
a une question déjà de ce qu'on va venir
constater qui est très factuel au niveau
de la lumière mais il y a une question
d'ambiance globale et l'ambiance globale
je la trouve beaucoup plus belle sur le
Galaxy S23 ultra clairement on va venir
continuer ici pour voir un peu la même
chose au niveau de l'écriture blue post
avec les petites lumières au-dessus
c'est très joli ça fonctionne ici aussi
et au niveau de l'iPhone c'est pas
mauvais ça fonctionne bien aussi une
fois de plus on est sur du très haut de
gamme donc c'est vraiment histoire de
chipoter on fait que chipoter ici au
niveau des lumières de la couronne la
lecture on lit bien tout c'est pas la
même chose mais là l'iPhone s'en sort
plutôt mieux je pense parce que si vous
regardez on voit mieux le sol peut-être
une question aussi du piqué qui nous
ramène un peu plus de détails ici on
voit mieux les carreaux qu'ici il y a un
peu moins de piquets c'est un peu moins
précis et même chose au niveau du pixel
7 Pro ici je vais venir préférer le sol
la matière que nous apporte cette photo
de nuit on continue ici au niveau de la
vitrine on le voit bien tout ça
fonctionne je vais préférer une fois de
plus le détail que nous apporte l'iPhone
ici vous voyez dans la photo je vais
avoir un peu plus de détails un peu plus
de matière que je vais venir retrouver
notamment ici si vous regardez voyez par
rapport à ici il y aura un peu moins de
matière ça reste du point de détail au
niveau de la brique aussi la voyez j'ai
un peu plus de matière qui ressemble
mieux par rapport aux autres c'était
sorti un peu plus le blanc en fait vous
voyez les joints entre mes briques que
je vois davantage que je les vois un
petit peu moins à côté donc on fait
avoir un peu plus de pick-up un peu plus
de matière c'est pas réellement du piqué
c'est l'algo qui vient de ressortir ça
pour venir compenser et c'est là où on
va aussi voir la puissance de Samsung on
est ici à Piccadilly Circus et
Piccadilly Circus il y a de la pub un
peu des écrans comme un pote Time Square
on n'est pas Time Square il y en a pas
de temps mais alors c'est pas pris
exactement au même moment donc ça peut
pas être vraiment face à face mais
quelque part c'est pourquoi parce que si
vous regardez toutes les publicités
elles ressortent toutes bien alors
l'idée c'est pas regarder les pubs mais
c'est de voir qu'il y a rien de cramé si
on regarde sur le pixel 7 Pro ah il est
un peu plus de mal là vous voyez là le
nez est cramé les cheveux la pub de coca
au centre elle galère un peu plus et
c'est pareil sur l'iPhone ça galère
davantage donc il y a une gestion des
hautes lumières et des lumières la nuit
qui va être bien meilleure une fois de
plus cette ambiance un peu plus douce au
niveau de la lumière qui ressort et un
peu plus foncé sur le haut légèrement
moins bruité que ce que j'ai ici sur le
pixel 7 pro et un tout petit peu moins
aussi que sur l'iPhone 14 pro max c'est
du point de détail à côté de ça si je
veux avoir une façade qui ressemble
mieux et bien la façade voyez elle
ressemble mieux de mon bâtiment ici sur
mon iphone 14 pro max que sur mon
samsung galaxy S23 ultra c'est une
question d'ambiance après de manière un
peu globale je vais préférer l'ambiance
ici que je retrouve au niveau du S23
ultra on continue ici à Soho beaucoup
plus de détails une fois de plus au
niveau de l'iPhone que j'en aurai un
petit peu moins sur les deux autres et
là c'est pareil on vient chercher ici au
niveau du bâtiment au niveau des hautes
lumières au niveau du détail là j'aime
vraiment bien là le travail qui est fait
au niveau de l'expo au niveau du je sais
pas comment vous expliquer ça mais point
de vue purement esthétique je trouve que
il y a un truc qui est joli dans cette
photo du Galaxy S23 ultra que j'avais
pas l'année dernière avec le S22 ultra
je tombais très joli je trouve un peu
l'ambiance que j'avais avec le finding 5
Pro je trouve vraiment belle esthétique
je trouve que le pixel 7 Pro même si il
est efficace aussi il fonctionne bien il
a pas ce côté joli l'iPhone ne sort pas
mal sur certains détails mais il y a des
choses qui sont moins jolies alors là je
pense que j'ai davantage bouger ça se
voit lorsque je viens de rapprocher là
le pixel 7 Pro s'en sort mieux ce que je
pense que j'ai bougé ici voyez bon
l'iPhone aussi s'en sort bien là je
pense que c'est l'iPhone là en fait le
pixel 7 pro et là le Samsung parce que
je pense que j'ai dû bouger au niveau de
ma main et j'ai plus de détails là au
niveau de la brique également un peu
plus de détails mais bon les 300
globalement pas mauvais bon ici le
Samsung un peu en dessous mais une fois
de plus pour que c'est moi qui bougeais
à la main voilà pour les photos nuages
je vais vous montrer du mode portrait
mode portrait intéressant on va voir le
détourage on va voir comment il fait le
job alors déjà de base il y a un truc à
savoir c'est que lorsque vous prenez une
photo en mode portrait avec votre
smartphone de Google votre pixel 7 pro
et là il va venir vous rapprocher
davantage à la différence de l'iPhone et
du Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra qui lui va
vous garder un petit peu à distance à
vous de vous rapprocher bon là c'est pas
ce qu'il y a de plus intéressant j'ai
rechuté de plus près c'était plus
efficace comme ça je suis très dubitatif
sur le choix qui a fait Google ici au
niveau de son pixel 7 Pro parce que je
trouve que la colo est pas très jolie
pour autant ça détour plutôt bien ça
détend même plutôt très très bien le
boulot est bien fait même entre les
doigts il s'y repère pas trop mal ça va
ça fonctionne bien mais au niveau du
visage voyez il y a l'espace de truc qui
est très bizarre au niveau de de la peau
il y a aussi un truc très bizarre aussi
au niveau du du Galaxy S23 ultra alors
vous fiez pas la lumière jaune à ce que
j'avais vraiment un éclairage jaune vers
moi c'est que je le trouve un peu moins
bon celui que j'ai préféré au niveau du
mode portrait c'est pour moi l'iPhone
l'iPhone sera meilleur au niveau du
détail je trouverai plus joli le
détourage est très très bon et
extrêmement bien maîtrisé il me repère
bien il me détourne bien magnifiquement
bien sur les détails au niveau de la
silhouette vous voyez ça fonctionne
super bien et on a rien à redire ici sur
le Galaxy S23 ultra c'est pareil il y a
des tours très très bien également je
leur trouvais quasiment les mêmes
détails qu'on va avoir ici entre ici et
ici peut-être légèrement plus accentué
sur l'iPhone 14 pro max pour moi le mode
portrait je veux dire que le Google
pixel pro et pas terrible du tout le
Samsung Galaxy S23 et pas mal et pour
moi le meilleur ici ça va être l'iPhone
14 pro max voilà au niveau de ce
comparatif alors on voyait je vous le
dis une fois de plus on est dans le très
haut de gamme donc c'est compliqué de
venir départager pour moi celui que je
vais vraiment préféré qui je trouve aura
la meilleure esthétique et une fois de
plus c'est très sympa que c'est très
impersonnel c'est une question de goût
ça va être cette fois-ci le Galaxy S23
ultra il est pas parfait vous avez vu
qu'il y a des choses où l'iPhone va être
meilleur l'iPhone va être meilleur au
niveau du détail au niveau de certaines
choses ce sera meilleur au niveau du
mode portrait au niveau des photos de
nuit sera bien meilleur au niveau par
exemple d'une brique au niveau d'un
détail sur un carrelage sur un sol sur
une ruelle ça sera beaucoup plus joli et
il sera très très efficace sur la
matière mais d'une façon globale au
niveau du traitement des hautes lumières
au niveau des photos au niveau de tout
ce qui va être purement esthétique je
trouve que le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra
s'en sort beaucoup mieux alors le pixel
7 Pro ça reste très intéressant parce
que c'est un très bon smartphone c'est
un très bon photophone il fonctionne
très très bien mais pour moi il en
dessous en dessous des deux il y a des
choses sur lesquelles il fonctionnera
très bien ils sont bien le faire mais il
lui manque un petit quelque chose au
niveau de l'âme qui fait que c'est très
imperceptible une fois de plus au niveau
du ressenti je trouve que le Galaxy S23
Ultra est vraiment au dessus alors
attendez on n'est pas non plus dans les
mêmes générations on peut pas venir
comparer les puces ne sont pas du tout
les mêmes Google reste très très bon au
niveau de son algorithme pour traiter
ses photos ils sont super bon là-dessus
mais je dois reconnaître que cette année
je suis vraiment tout particulièrement
bluffé par ce Galaxy S23 ultra équipé du
slendragon 8g 2 que je trouve juste
magnifique donc c'est vraiment ma grosse
grosse préférence gros coup de coeur sur
ce smartphone début 2023 l'iPhone 14 pro
max reste quand même très très beau et
vous serez pas déçu si vous voulez très
très bonne photo ici il y a aucun
problème mais c'est vrai que le pixel 7
pro pour moi bon il est alors il est un
peu moins cher on peut le trouver moins
cher bien évidemment ce qui peut aussi
expliquer peut-être un peu la différence
mais voilà pour moi début 2023 si vous
voulez un excellent photophone qui sera
très très bon pas très très bon partout
vous voyez au niveau de la caméra de
selfie sera un peu moins bon là il fait
maintenant on se prend Max sera bien
meilleur au niveau du mode portrait il
sera pas mauvais mais bon l'iPhone 14
pro max sera bien meilleur mais si on
est pragmatique 2 secondes le mode
portrait on en fait globalement pas des
MAS à vous je sais pas moi pas des mains
d'ailleurs dites-le-moi dans les
commentaires et les photos en selfie on
en fait beaucoup mais à ce moment-là ce
que je vous recommande de faire c'est de
prendre votre Smartphone vous mettre sur
votre caméra et puis prenez une habitude
c'est que vous prenez votre Smartphone
vous le retournez et vous vous prenez en
photo comme ça et ça fonctionnera ça
sera bien meilleur voilà d'autant plus
qu'avec Samsung si vous mettez votre
main devant vous voyez hop il va venir
déclencher et il vous fera une photo
donc ça c'est très très cool d'ailleurs
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous
lequel vous venez préférer à la suite de
cette très longue vidéo est-ce que vous
êtes plus team Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra
est-ce que vous êtes team iPhone 14 pro
max ou est-ce que vous êtes team Google
pixel 7 Pro marquer le moi en bas dans
les commentaires et puis on fera
d'autres comparatifs super intéressant
avec le Xiaomi 13 pro ça c'est la
version chinoise j'attends d'avoir la
version française pour pouvoir vous
faire un vrai comparatif en face du
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra pour voir un
processeur équivalent quelle différence
y a en plus ce qui est très intéressant
cette année c'est qu'au niveau du Xiaomi
13 pro et bien on a un partenariat avec
Leica et ça à mon avis ça va être pas
mal non plus voilà on en parle très
bientôt si un de ces smartphones vous
intéresse je vous mets le lien en bas
dans la description et une fois de plus
bravo ça me saoule pour moi vous
l'emport ez pas haut la main mais vous
l'emportez et ça c'est beau allez je
vous embrasse à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]